So, as Dr.Rosenberg just described, it was Charles Darwin who first, conducted
research on emotion expression. He argued that emotions were expressed
similarly in humans, and in even non-human animals sometimes. And this is the
idea of universality. Emotions are universally expressed, in similar ways, all
over the world. So a smile, for instance, is a smile regardless of who
expresses it. But Darwin's work was not systematic. So in the 1960's, Paul
Ekman and his colleague Wallace Friesen took up Darwin's work. And became more
systematic and more scientific. They conducted research on universality in
western cultures, and found universality. That is, people expressed emotions
very much the same way, and interpreted them very much the same way. But this
was just in the west. It wasn't a true test of universality. So, in the late
1960s, Paul Ekman and an anthropologist went to Papua New Guinea to conduct
research. And they went to Papua New Guinea because it was a preliterate
culture that had no contact whatsoever at that time to the west. And he found
evidence for universality, anger, disgust, fear, happiness, sadness and
surprise. And later on, he and his colleagues, found universal evidence for
contempt.